We all like to think we are unique.
So they might be your DNA,
your fingerprints,
iris scans or retinal patterns.
We are always leaving digital traces
wherever we go,
and we can never be truly offline.
There's always the suggestion that
collecting vast amounts of biometrics
is going to be used
for something nefarious.
But it can actually create
some incredibly positive situations.
So there's a saying in Chinese -
if you haven't done anything wrong,
why would you be scared of ghosts?
Businesses are typically designed
to make money
and they will not have,
in general,
as much interest
in protecting your rights.
You are very much the product.
Fingerprints are something
that were used
in very, very early
Chinese pottery, for example.
Where the potter would leave
their fingerprint in the wet clay.
If you watch television and
you read all these forensic fiction,
fingerprints solve everything
and the honest truth is they don't.
The fingerprint in isolation
has no value
in telling you who the person is
until you have something
to compare it with.
DNA is still the gold standard
when we can identify the source
of the DNA, whose DNA it is.
What we're not very good
at understanding
is how did it get there?
So how did your DNA
get on to the knife?
Is it because you used the knife
to stab somebody?
Or is it because
you shook hands with somebody
who used the knife
to stab somebody?
If you look at
the little skin creases
that you have over your knuckles,
they're different on every finger,
they're different
across your two hands,
they're different on identical twins.
And when infrared light
shines on your veins
it interacts with
the deoxygenated blood
and your veins stand out
like black tramlines.
There is a really strong chance
that the hand
and of all the biometrics
that we can see in the hand
may well be that 'holy grail'
that we search for
which is, it's unique.
So there is a global trend
across the world
where computers collect more data.
And therefore
governments and corporations
are locked in a race
where they're trying to collect
a mass amount
of identifying information.
Gathering data about people who live
in a city or who live in a borough
is now a critical part
of the functioning government.
If you want to
allocate your resources properly
you need the data.
Wouldn't it just be wonderful
if you could put your hand or your
finger on whatever devices,
it knows exactly who you are,
it knows exactly
what your health statistics are,
what the probability is
of you catching cancer
because of the gene
that you've got -
the options are just limitless.
Netflix released
what they thought was
anonymised records
of movie watching,
and their aim was to try and improve
their recommendation algorithms.
In other words, if you've watched
movies A, B and C
you're really quite likely
to enjoy watching movie D.
Unfortunately researchers
quickly realised
they were able to cross-reference
these anonymous records with IMDB,
which is an online
movie rating service.
And once you can identify
who someone is
you can work out
their sexual preferences
to some degree of probability.
It would be taking in all sorts
of data from local government,
from your schools,
from your workplaces,
from your companies,
where you go, your GPS data -
putting it into one single score
which evaluates how trustworthy -
in quotation marks - you are.
Like an Uber score
where, with a lower credit score,
you might not be able
to borrow money,
you might not be able to travel
on public transport.
We're always
in a cyber-physical space.
Every place we go to will have
some cyber element around it.
There'll be cameras
capturing information.
There'll be things
that are connecting to your phone
that you may or may not
be aware of.
We are always leaving digital traces
wherever we go
and we can never be truly offline.
In Shenzhen, when you're
crossing the road,
there are CCTV cameras
that use facial recognition
to see if you're jaywalking or not
and then identifying
who that citizen is
and then sometimes you'll be
displayed on a big billboard
on the other side of the road
in a sort of 'name and shame' action.
What happens in China
and in other countries
is a cautionary lesson for all of us
that unless you have
proper regulation
the gathering of your data
is a real danger to our human rights.
The landscape is
continually changing.
Who would have thought ten years ago
we'd have had all this collection
that we have now?
Who would have thought about
the ways data can be used
and abused.
So regulation is always
chasing where we are
with the current technology.
If they provide you with pages
and pages of terms and conditions
well, that's transparent,
so we can all read those.
However do we really have the time
and the knowledge
to read all of those?
No.
So are we really in a situation
where it's not transparent
but it's apparent to us?
Are we aware?
Biometric data is very personal.
It's your data
because it's about you.
They're your fingerprints
or it's your DNA.
Once it's given away
it is incredibly hard,
if not impossible,
to take it back.
I have a real conflict
between how much of my information
I want to share
and how much information
I want to have available to me
when I go to a crime scene.
I want to be able to find
the pieces of DNA,
I want to be able
to find the fingerprints.
I want to be able to get every single
bit of information I can
to make sure justice is served.
But of course here I am, sitting
in the middle of that crime scene,
not wanting to give mine.
That old saying,
if you have nothing to hide
you have nothing to fear -
that kind of approach
doesn't value our privacy.
If the government said,
"We're going to put a camera in
every single bedroom in the country
that would film what happens
in your bedroom,
but we assure you we will only turn
it on if we think there's suspicion."
I think most members of the public
would say,
"I don't have anything to hide
but this is my bedroom,
this is private."
In reality, there are so many ways
to gather data about you nowadays
and it can give as detailed
information, in some ways, about you
as if you were having a camera
in your bedroom.
Large size datasets or databases
are incredibly useful
but the critical thing
is that they are correctly used.
That's going to be a very, very
big question that we need to resolve
as this digital word really
starts to accelerate around us.